[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
hey could you hold this for a second
thanks
hey is this anybody's bike no
hey hey buddy is this your bike not
change does anyone have a pen you have a
pen
[Music]
everybody good
[Music]
okay spiderman don't flip
[Music]
hey buddy shouldn't steal cars is bad
it's my car
dumbass hey shut that up i was just
doing it at my car
i'm working nice come on dude that's not
your car
[Applause]
how are you how's your mind
oh no my friends are up there what uh
don't worry ma'am everything's gonna be
okay
excuse me excuse me oh my god that's
tall
[Music]
oh my god look at the ceiling just stay
calm everyone
oh we are going to die here
estimating 10 minutes before
catastrophic failure
okay guys i know that was scary but our
safety systems are working
the safety systems are completely
failing we're very safe
in here the occupants are an imminent
mortal danger
no i'm going as fast as i can you now
have 125 seconds until catastrophic
failure what
why unexpected motion has caused the
deterioration to escalate
how do i get in there activating
reconnaissance drone
whoa has that been there this whole time
that's awesome
locating optimal entry point
proceed to southwest window karen i'm on
my way
[Music]
[Music]
god
what's wrong you have reached the
southwest window why are you hesitating
never been this high before you have
also not reinstalled your parachute so a
fall from this hike would most likely be
lethal
perfect
why is it not breaking it's 4-inch
ballistic glass you'll have to create
more momentum
[Music]
return immediately okay who's next
me it's my turn seriously
stand down return to the ground
immediately
[Music]
return to the ground or we will open
fire go up go up
[Music]
i'm gonna die
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey how you doing don't worry about i
got you yes
yes big guy quit moving around sorry sir
so sorry
[Music]
[Music]
is everyone okay this is your chance
peter
kiss her
thank you
hey pedro
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
bingo
[Music]
your wigs your wig's just
time to go home pete i'm trying to save
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
eh
[Music]
you